the first signing is the bilateral
Canada Ukraine youth Mobility agreement
the signatory for Canada is The
Honorable Melanie Jolie Minister of
Foreign Affairs and for Ukraine Her
Excellency Julia kovalev Ambassador
extraordinary and planet potentiary of
Ukraine to Canada
and Ukraine have enjoyed a close
relationship
Canada became the first Western country
to recognize Ukraine's Independence on
December 2nd 1991.
our bilateral relationship is
strengthened by warm people-to-people
ties rooted in the Ukrainian Canadian
community of 1.4 million people
prime minister Trudeau visited cave on
May 8 2022.
along with the Deputy Prime Minister
Christia Freeland and the Minister of
Foreign Affairs Melanie Jolie to Mark
the reopening of the Canadian embassy in
Ukraine
from the beginning of Russia's illegal
and unjustifiable invasion in 2022
Canada has provided multi-dimensional
Aid to Ukraine
Financial humanitarian military and
development Aid as well as peace and
stabilization assistance
Canada is firmly committed to Ukraine's
sovereignty territorial integrity
foreign
Island and Independence this is prime
minister shmihara's first official visit
to Canada his visit marks a new chapter
in the historic partnership between our
two countries
the second document to be signed
is the joint declaration by the
governments of Canada and Ukraine on the
modernization of the Canada Ukraine Free
Trade Agreement
the second document to be signed is the
joint declaration by the governments of
Canada and Ukraine
on the modernization of the Canada
Ukraine Free Trade Agreement
the signatory for Canada will be the
bright honorable Justin Trudeau prime
minister of Canada and for Ukraine his
Excellency Denise mihal prime minister
of Ukraine the original Free Trade
Agreement brought benefits to both our
countries the modernization will allow
us to further deepen our bilateral
commercial relations for the long term
thank you
hold on
[Applause]
to the moment no reconnaissance hello
everyone
we recognize
that we are gathered today on the
traditional lands of many nations
and many others now the people of
Ukraine have been heroically resisting
Putin's barbaric invasion
the very young and the very old
remaining Resolute and defiant
as the air raid sirens bring out
civilian recruits and battle-hardened
soldiers
women and men in sustained and brutal
combat
and political leaders
who like the remarkable people they
represent
could not have been prepared for the
hand history dealt them
but who have rallied the world with
their resolve
ukrainians have been fighting for their
country
for their sovereignty and for the future
of Ukraine
and in
the freezing muddy trenches all across
Ukraine they have also been fighting our
fights
fight for democracy
and that's why Canada
is so determined to ensure that Ukraine
wins
it is so certain that Ukraine will win
with the highest per capita contribution
in the G7 Canada is committed
to sending more than eight billion
dollars
in total in support to Ukraine
[Music]
including a 2.4 billion dollar loan
that we announced in our budget last
month
care we have provided a military and
humanitarian assistance
we will be there until Ukraine wins the
summer and I speak often
and when we do I often reflect on the
fact
that I talked to him in my office in
Ottawa or in my home here in Toronto
but while I'm doing that from the
comfort and safety of Canada I know that
than this is in Ukraine leading a nation
at War
Dennis was in Ukraine in cave on that
terrifying night in that now famous
video when president zielinski said
I am here
we are here
tooth
we are here here here here
and he has also become an inspiration to
me
just as I know all Canadians are
inspired by the remarkably brave people
of Ukraine
it was an honor for me and my family to
host in this at my home here in Toronto
last night
and to welcome him to Canada
that is why Dennis I would like to thank
you from the bottom of my heart for your
leadership for your bravery your courage
and your friendship
I am deeply grateful to you Canada is
grateful to you
and democracy is grateful to you
very sincerely for your leadership
for your courage and for your friendship
I am so grateful to you
Canada is grateful to you
and democracy is grateful to you
now we have two prime ministers here and
very early in the war
when most in the west thought cave was
sure to fall
Minister Trudeau said to me
that he believed Ukraine would resist
and that resistance would make Ukraine
stronger
our prime minister in those very early
days
compared to the battle for cave to the
Blitz
and he predicted that the Ukrainian
people would rally and unite in the face
of the challenge
just as the British people did
and our prime minister was of course
right you did
our government has been United in our
support for Ukraine because we know that
this fight
the fight for democracy is Canada's
fight too
that belief and resolve comes directly
from our prime minister
now with very great pleasure turn it
over to prime minister Trudeau and to a
man to whom democracy owes a very great
deal the prime minister of Ukraine
thank you
Mercy Christian
I am very pleased today to be hosting
the prime minister of Ukraine Dennis
Julie Freeland thank you for your words
uh Minister Anand great to see you uh as
well as a number of our strong MPS with
great Ukrainian communities Julie
zerowitz a referrani James Maloney of
course Yvonne Baker uh good to see you
Alexander president of the uh you uh
Ukrainian Canadian Congress uh
Ambassador and other dear friends
I took the opportunity to reiterate our
support to ukrainians against Russia's
brutal Invasion we will continue to be
there to support them as long as
necessary Canada will always be there to
defend our values like democracy and the
rules-based international order
for more than a year now Canada has been
helping ukrainians defend themselves by
sending military assistance including
tanks and armored vehicles ammunition
weapons and other equipment
today we're announcing we'll be sending
even more weapons
sourced from Colt Canada we'll be
sending 21
000 assault rifles 38 machine guns and
over 2.4 million rounds of ammunitions
this will help the Armed Forces of
Ukraine continue to defend their freedom
and fight for Ukraine's territorial
integrity
something prime minister shmihal and I
discussed today was also the financial
situation of his country and the efforts
to rebuild Ukraine
to support essential services including
pension payments purchasing Fuel and
restoring damaged energy infrastructure
Canada has now dispersed a 2.4 billion
dollar loan announced in our budget
2023.
we also talked about the Reconstruction
efforts and we will continue to do so
this afternoon with Canadian Business
Leaders to see how the private sector
we also signed a youth Mobility
agreement in both of our countries when
Russian troops have lasted Ukraine and
the situation is safe are youth will be
able to visit and work in Canada and
Ukraine that is a measure which will
enable both of our populations to come
even closer
another thing that we'll continue to
bring our two countries closer is trade
that's why I was so glad to sit down
with Denny Dennis and sign a joint
Declaration on the conclusion of
negotiations for the modernization of
the Canada Ukraine Free Trade Agreement
it is a
comprehensive and very very strong
agreement that I know will be a model
for the kind of strong engagement that
Ukraine can and will have not just with
Canada but around the world as well and
we're privileged to be once again an
early friend on that we're both deeply
committed to implement it as soon as
possible it'll strengthen our trade ties
and help support Ukraine's economic
recovery not just with Canada but with
the world
Canada has a lot to offer whether it's
skilled workers technological expertise
or natural resources I know that during
prime minister shmihal's visit the
Saskatoon based company camaco signed a
major con Supply contract with energo
atom in Ukraine building on their
partnership agreement
camaco will provide the necessary
uranium to meet you clear
Ukraine's nuclear fuel needs until 2035
which will help Ukraine keep the lights
on while creating and supporting good
middle-class jobs here in Canada
another important way to support Ukraine
is to hold Russia responsible for its
actions Canada has now imposed sanctions
on more than 2 400 individuals and
entities in Russia Ukraine and Belarus
and today we are announcing new
sanctions to maintain the pressure on
the Russian regime we're announcing new
sanctions on 14 Russian individuals and
34 entities including security targets
linked to the Wagner group in addition
to further put in pressure to further
pressure Putin's enablers in Belarus
we're announcing additional sanctions on
nine entities related to the Belarusian
financial sector
Dennis thank you again for your visit my
friend Canada will continue to be
steadfast in our support of Ukraine as
you defend yourselves heroically against
you putrins brutal barbaric invasion
the courage of ukrainians is heroic
but as you well know than if you are
standing up for more than just the
values and the principles that
ukrainians hold dear you are standing up
for the values and principles that
underpin all of our freedoms and all of
our democracies and it is an
extraordinary pleasure and privilege to
be able to stand with you right now as
we have for many years as we will long
into the future
Canadians stand with you and always will
thank you everyone I'm now very happy to
pass it over to my friend and Canada's
friend
prime minister Dennis
[Applause]
prime minister
Dear Justin
dear friends and colleagues
dear Deputy Prime Minister
distinguished
parliamentarians ministers dear friends
callings members of parliament the
people of Canada the people of Ukraine
today in Canada we had a great fruitful
discussion with the prime minister of
Canada
his government
Canada and Ukraine have a special
relationship it's not just a strategic
partnership it's a true friendship
between our countries and between our
people
Canada is the first country of the West
for the recognize Ukraine's Independence
today Canada is one of the leaders of
the Western Alliance that supports
our fight against the unprovoked Russian
aggression Canada is one of the top five
supporters of Ukraine in its military
assistance we are grateful to the
government of Canada and to the people
of Canada who help us fight for
independence and our democratic values
during today's meeting with the prime
minister of Canada we had the
opportunity to discuss a broad range of
questions pertaining to the relationship
between our two countries we were able
to support what the Prime Minister said
we have reached the final agreement and
signed the joint Declaration on
modernizing the free trade agreement
between Canada and Ukraine in particular
there were 18 chapters that were agreed
10 of which were brand new it's trade
and services finances investment trade
and gender equality
they pertain to indigenous peoples
regulatory policy
support of small and medium Enterprises
we expect that the new modernized
agreement will increase the level of
bilateral trade and open new
economic opportunities for our countries
the next element we discussed was the
military assistance to Ukraine to enable
Ukraine to defend itself and stress that
and free the occupied territories of
Ukraine
we are grateful that Canada joined the
leopard Coalition
we hope that there will be more heavy
weapons such as tanks
armored vehicles
and ammunition this is something we
discussed today as well
we also discussed
the participation of Canadian companies
in
rebuilding Ukraine the largest project
since World War II it's about 411
billion dollars the amount of Damages
that Russia caused to Ukraine and these
are the amounts that are needed in order
to rebuild the infrastructure
their residential infrastructure
demining agriculture energy
we are expecting other decisions from
the government of Ukraine to motivate
Canadian businesses
further Canada is one of the leaders in
sanction policies against Russia and I
hope this continues
we hope that more and more companies
assets of Russia in Canada will be
seized and used to
fund the rebuilding of Ukraine the
frozen assets the Frozen funds must
become the basis to rebuilding Ukraine
Russia must be held responsible they
have to pay for what they've ruined this
would be fair I would like to thank
Canada and Canadians for supporting
Ukraine and ukrainians Canadian weapons
help us defend ourselves financial
services financial assistance helps us
keep jobs and help those who have lost
everything due to Russia's Terror
Canada's assistance in humanitarian
areas allows us to clear Minds on
agricultural fields and
prosecute military crimes crimes
Canada does everything to help Ukraine
stop the aggressor we all understand the
risks for the Free World
that the aggression that Russia brings
evil is for good men to do nothing
the only thing necessary for the evil to
Triumph is for good men to do nothing
we are grateful for the support of our
country we thank Canada
for believing in US
we believe that Canada's support will
continue until Ukraine is triumphant
today we had a very fruitful discussions
negotiations
we have
spoken about
broadening the Coalition in support of
Ukraine about the steps that are needed
for the next step of the
counter-offensive and fourth
liberating our lands and from all of us
I want to say thank you Canada thank you
prime minister thank you dear Justin
thank you for your personal efforts for
your team's efforts for your
government's efforts I'm grateful to the
parliament of Canada for the unanimous
support of the many initiatives that
help strengthen Ukraine and I'm very
grateful to the people of Canada for
their resilience and for their
unwavering steadfast support thank you
glory to Ukraine glory to Canada
first question is to Global over to you
good afternoon prime minister Trudeau
Catherine Ellsworth of global news here
this is in regards to a Trudeau
Foundation question the entire board and
the CEO of the foundation resigned this
morning they cited the recent
politization of their work are you
concerned about the long-term stability
of the organization and that the Fallout
from allegations of foreign interference
is extending beyond your government
as you well know the Trudeau Foundation
is a a foundation with which I have
absolutely no intersection it was
established to promote knowledge and
academic research into the humanities
following the death of my father and has
had an extraordinary impact on academic
institutions and on you know brilliant
Canadians it is a shame to see the level
of toxicity and political polarization
that is going on in our country these
days but I am certain that the Trudeau
foundation will be able to continue to
ensure that research into the social
studies and Humanities at the highest
levels across Canadian academic
institutions continues for many years to
come
second question is to Forum TV over to
you
good afternoon Mr Trudeau and Mr Ishmael
good evening and welcome to Canada I
have a question for prime minister
we know how much support Canada has
already provided to Ukraine and it
continues and here's my question I know
that this morning you've had the ability
to meet with the Ukrainian diaspora
to what extent
does Ukraine feel the support of
Canada's diaspora and all the more could
we do in order to bring Ukraine's
Victory closer thank you
thank you
indeed Ukraine feels the Colossal
support of Canada in every area
Financial sanctions weapons freezing
confiscating assets Canada is a leader
in all of these areas and we really
appreciate it
without
them we as you've heard we've received
2.4 billion
from Canada we received weapons from
Canada and we received Direct
support from Ukrainian community in
Canada and from Canadians regular
Canadians Canadian people and it's very
warmly
accepted by the people in Ukraine it's
direct People to People relations people
feel the warmth the warmth emotions it
brings a boost to our morale we feel
that we are not alone in our struggle
and that we have the support directly
from the people
the political level of our partners is
responding to the communities and
Canadian Community stands with Ukraine
and we're very grateful for that today
we discussed that Ukraine received 50
million dollars in donations
for medication for humanitarian needs
for food and other needs we really
appreciate it we're very grateful and of
course we believe that together we will
be victorious in this unprovoked and
brutal War thank you for this sincere
and emotional question that you brought
forth
documents suggest that Ukraine's air
defense in the previous situation right
now you have already committed to
providing one anti-air missile system to
Ukraine is there anything else Canada
will or can do to improve Canada
Ukraine's defense defense systems and do
you have any comments on the leaks in
general
we will continue to support Ukraine with
everything needed for as long as
necessary we stand with Ukraine and we
always will Canadians have been
absolutely steadfast uh partially
because of the extraordinary work of the
Ukrainian diaspora here in Canada but
their
have been so many
strong and impactful members of the
Ukrainian Canadian community over the
past decades that
I think as Vladimir Putin was surprised
at the strength of ukrainians Defending
themselves in those first days of the
war people around the world were
surprised to discover how courageous and
strong and Valiant ukrainians were
Canadians were not so surprised because
we have had the privilege of knowing
ukrainians Among Us for many many many
decades and we know the kind of strength
and resilience you have
the support we will continue to deliver
military economic humanitarian
trade support commercial support working
with grains working as friends on
building a prosperous future for
ourselves and for those who share our
values around the world will continue we
will always step up and I have no
conflict no doubt in my mind I have full
confidence that Ukraine will prevail
next question
hi Adrian Gabriel CTV national news a
question for you prime minister Trudeau
I've been speaking with retired Canadian
military who are in Ukraine helping
trained Ukrainian Fighters as well as
International retired military they put
together a report that details and
alleges that unfortunately ukrainians
command structure military structure is
still operating in a Soviet era they're
not using NATO training and they say
that it's costing lives it's costing
resources and it's prolonging the war as
Canadians and our government give
billions of dollars to Ukraine is that a
concern for you
um I actually disagree with that report
uh in in how you've characterized it one
of the reasons the Ukrainian military
has been able to stand so effectively
against the Russian invasion this past
year has been because countries like
Canada and others have been there for
many years here Canada showed up in
about 2015 with operation unifier to
help train the Ukrainian Defense Force
and we have now trained over 35
000 members of Ukraine's military and
that has made a extraordinary impact in
their ability to execute on some very
sophisticated military Maneuvers and
been incredibly successful and continue
to be to be so and will continue to be
so uh obviously the much of the
equipment they have is Soviet era which
is why we are so active in delivering
some of the more modern West
technologies that we have but I would
know for a second hesitate in
characterizing the abilities and the
approach of the Ukrainian military
forces and the volunteers and those who
serve as being exceptional and one of
the reasons why we are still
seeing such strength from Ukraine and
ukrainians well over a year into what
was supposed to be you know a couple of
weeks of of Russian overwhelming
ukraines Putin miscalculated uh and uh
it is to the world's benefit that
Ukraine is as strong as it is
towards the Prime Minister thank you so
much so I should note that this training
commissions and unifier is crucially
important for ukrainians and I should
repeat that more than 35
000 and we ask for continuation of these
trainings for our soldiers it's
crucially important now especially now
when our army is fighting with Russian
according to the NATO standards by NATO
Weaponry
in NATO style I should note that Russian
armies Soviet style Army and never small
Soviet Army will win big Soviet Army so
the only possibility to win this war to
have very strong NATO standardized
standard design
Army in Ukraine and we actually realize
this strategy and our army now is
absolutely created according to the NATO
standards use NATO weaponry and I should
emphasize that our army our society is
absolutely encouraged to go into ahead
liberate our land we are tired it's
naturally because we fight more than one
year with a second so named second army
in the world but we are not exhausted we
are not fatigue we have encouraged to go
into our hand and support of our
partners support of government of Canada
prime minister his team is fulfilled Us
by this
feeling and we are sure that we will win
this war all together thank you one
quick follow-up for prime minister
Trudeau prime minister Trudeau are you
willing to say publicly to Canadians
that Canada is now at a pro in a proxy
war with Russia if you can give us a yes
or no answer and a brief
reasoning why or why not
Russia's illegal invasion of Ukraine
upended 80 years
of Peace stability and security around
the world one of the most prosperous
eras the world has ever known we have
all been benefited from that
immeasurably everywhere around the world
Russia's decision
to end
that is to violate
the U.N
Charter
to overturn international law to
arbitrarily choose to redraw lines on a
map
is of course of deep concern to Canada
in regards to our friends in Ukraine
but should be of real concern to
everyone around the world everywhere
around the world there are authoritarian
dictators looking at Vladimir Putin
curious to see if he will succeed
because everywhere around the world
there are neighbors with larger armies
than the country beside them saying oh
wouldn't it be nice to redraw the map
wouldn't it be nice to be able to invade
and benefit from that and get a few more
resources or or bring in uh people who
speak the same language
this choice that Canada has to stand
unequivocally with Ukraine is yes of
course about the Deep friendship and the
the personal and family and and
demographic ties that we've had with
Ukraine for over a century
but it is also about the right thing to
do
right now Ukraine is yes fighting for
its territorial Integrity its right to
determine its own future and that is
very important and we'll be there for
that
but it's also fighting for the values
and the principles that underpin all of
our democracies
all of the stability and freedom that
we've been able to build in
international law over the past years
that's why Canada stands unequivocally
with Ukraine that's why we will continue
to do everything necessary to ensure
that Ukraine prevails
[Applause]
my first question is for uh the
Ukrainian prime minister uh what do you
most urgently need from Canada in terms
of heavy military weaponry weaponry and
does your list include fighter jets
thank you so much for your question we
discuss all Argent needs today was prime
minister and his team
first of all we are preparing for our
counter offensive we need more
ammunition we need more Weaponry we need
more military equipment we discuss all
the details I can explain this publicly
but Canada Supply and support us in
supplying many military equipment and
ammunition together with other allies
and our partners the second issue was
sanction support so the next packages of
sanctions on the personalities Russian
persons and their Industries and in
details I explain and describe why
should we Implement sanctions on nuclear
sphere of Russia and nuclear industry
because of their nuclear blackmailing
all over the world and European
continent we also discuss other steps
about confiscation of Frozen Russian
assets and Canada here is again number
one in sense of creating of residents
for the confiscation of frozen assets of
Russian oligarchs so all of these issues
are crucially important for Ukraine now
and during this tough times for Ukraine
inches
follow a question about the leaks of
classified documents do you think there
will be an impact on operations in
Ukraine
and could you confirm that there have
been incidents affecting our gas
pipelines
well we know that we will continue to
work with our partners throughout the
world to defend Ukraine
to ensure that Ukraine can
stand strong against Russia
and that Russia does not manage to
realign the global order in its favor
nor determine the future of the
Ukrainian people that's why we'll be
there for them
with regard to the cyber attacks you're
referring to
uh
against Canadian gas infrastructure
I can confirm
that no physical harm was caused to
these pieces of Canadian infrastructure
confirm
in regards to the reports of cyber
attacks against Canadian energy
infrastructure
um
I can confirm that there was no physical
damage to any Canadian energy
infrastructure following cyber attacks
next question
my name is Yuri klufas I'm reporting for
contact a Ukrainian TV network it's
great to see both countries on the same
stage after all we have the same great
neighbor
Ukraine is experiencing an invasion in
the war most Canadians may not know it
but we're having a similar invasion in
the North Pole which we'll learn about
very soon the
both both of you have mentioned
democracy democratic values and the
greatest threat it seems war or no war
uh to the world of democracy is Soviet
disinformation and uh or Russian
disinformation and hacking uh Soviet
because everything continues on in the
same way uh the question to our prime
minister
what is Ukraine doing in terms of
countering this Russian disinformation
and uh to prime minister Trudeau maybe
on a lighter note your website has been
down today is that due to uh Russian
hacking
so thank you for your question I should
emphasize that Ukraine for the last
nine years in in war was Russia and it
was not only military war in military
sense it was
a hybrid War which include all kinds of
aggression
hybrid aggression in sense of Migrant
influences on the European Union and on
the Ukraine cyber influences this
information influences propaganda
influences and or energy blackmailing of
Ukraine and European Union so during the
last nine years we were under strong and
very
strong pressure of Russia by the hybrid
method of attack on Ukrainian
infrastructure Society what we have
implemented in Ukraine first of all we
create all the infrastructure to
deter Russian propaganda and Russian
influences hybrid influences on
Ukrainian Society we closed all their
channels for this propaganda in this
information our secret Services works
for the last years we work closely with
intelligence of European Union United
States Canada and we create very strong
cyber security centers in Ukraine
anti-propaganda and anti-disinformation
Center in Ukraine we work closely with
our European partners and share this
experience great European experience
with our partners and especially in the
Cyber sphere in the cyber security
because during this nine years Russia
many thousand times attacked Ukrainian
infrastructure civilian energy
infrastructure by cyber attacks and
during this war we have hundreds and
thousands cyber attacks on our
infrastructure and we may share this
experience we do it really we Implement
all of this projects and methods and
actually this is very practical issue
and methods so first of all
I think that our colleagues should take
a look and close Russian propaganda this
informational channels it's very
important step to stop this this
information but they also use other
hybrid methods and you may see it during
this war all around the world because
they try to realize this in Ukraine 10
years ago but now they they have very
good practice and they share it on the
all countries on the all Partners we
should be very United very United don't
believe any their special psychological
informational operations and to go to
the Victory and to go to stop this
Russian propaganda in this information
thank you so much
um as you know it's not uncommon for
Russian hackers to Target countries as
they are showing their steadfast support
for Ukraine as they're welcoming
Ukrainian delegations or leadership to
visit so the timing isn't surprising
but in case anyone was wondering uh
Russia being able to bring down an
official government of Canada web page
for a few hours is in no way going to
dissuade us from our uh un uh unshakable
support of Ukraine
uh
as people probably know
it is by no means rare to see Russian
cyber attacks targeting countries that
are showing their support to Ukraine
particularly at times
when a high-level political delegation
like this one is visiting would luckily
be very clear
the fact that unofficial government of
Canada website was down just for a few
hours that will not in any way deter us
from our present and unshakable support
for Ukraine as it faces
Russia's attack last question and
follow-up
um my first question is for uh prime
minister Trudeau the mass casualty
commission has made recommendations to
address the issue of intimate partner
violence in Canada are you considering
taking up their recommendations
including appointing a national office
that tackles gender-based violence and a
National Registry of ipv event offenders
the mass casualty commission following
the worst ever
Mass killing in Canadian history of
three years ago in and around
quarterback Nova Scotia
the commission did extraordinary work
3 000 Pages worth of
research reflection recommendations
we are taking the time to look very very
carefully at all those recommendations
and I can tell you we will be talking
soon about how we will be moving forward
including on some very very strong
recommendations
on combating intimate partner violence
Canada has for the past number of years
move forward with a very strong
gender-based violence strategy but there
is always more to do and that's exactly
what we will continue to look at
including drawing on some of those
excellent recommendations
in regards to the CEO and the board of
directors resigning from the Trudeau
Foundation given that politicized uh
given that they cited politicization
will you continue to appoint people
connected to the foundation to do work
for your government
foreign
those people
who are trying to
get short-term political gain by
increasing polarization and partisanship
in this country by launching completely
unfounded and ungrounded attacks against
Charities or foundations
um
must not succeed
Canada is a place where
we support
good works of all different types
and we need to continue to do that
I am I have no doubt
that the Trudeau Foundation like
foundations and Charities that
conservative politicians have attacked
in the past will continue
to do the excellent work that it will do
but as I've said many times it's a
foundation in my father's name that I
have no director in direct connection
with
um
I have no doubt that despite the attacks
of conservative politicians that have
been going on for years now
on the matter of charitable
organizations and Foundations
and attacks on people who are getting
involved to improve their communities
and Country in a non-partisan fashion
or rather these people will continue to
do their work despite the attacks
the attacks of politicians who want to
make our public debate more toxic
increase the level of polarization
foreign
especially in the political Arena
despite all this good people will
continue to work hard
in order to improve the country
and will not be affected by people who
are simply looking to score short-term
political points at the expense of
individuals and organizations that are
serving their country in the common good
as you know the Trudeau Foundation was
named after my father after his death
in order to advance research in social
sciences
I have no direct or indirect connection
with that Foundation
but I know that they will continue to do
excellent work
to advance important debates in this
area for today
thank you
[Applause]